seit heute prüft die eu den
beitrittsantrag der ukraine in die
europäische union und das während in dem
land seit zwölf tagen ein furchtbarer
krieg tobt putins krieg der verneint die
nationale identität der ukraine und
träumt wohl davon das land in seinem
gruß russisches reich zu reintegrieren
doch die ukrainer leisten tapferen
widerstand und der westen ist so einig
wie lange nicht allerdings auch darin
nicht militärisch einzugreifen
bundeskanzler scholz spricht von einer
zeitenwende
was bedeutet die diagnostizierte
zeitenwende für die ukraine für
deutschland für die eu und eine neue
weltordnung mit diesen fragen begrüße
ich sie sehr herzlich bei unter den
linden
[Musik]
und ich begrüße sehr herzlich hier am
tisch nicola beer die vize präsidentin
des europa im europäischen parlament ist
von der fdp herzlich willkommen man sie
und ich begrüße sehr herzlich roderich
kiesewetter von der cdu
oberst ade in der bundeswehr außerdem
vorsitzende des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums und ob man für seine
fraktion im auswärtigen ausschuss
herzlich willkommen auch an sie frau
bierkrieg einen aggressions krieg mitten
in europa
ist der krieg wieder eine kategorie der
politik geworden kann man das so sehen
muss man sich das eingestehen und das
ist ein ganz brutaler angriffskrieg
putins gegen alle regeln des
internationalen rechts
das undenkbare ist möglich geworden ich
glaube nichts von dem was wir heute
tagtäglich auf den bildschirm sehen
hätten wir vor einem monat noch für
möglich gehalten
ich finde es gut dass die
staatengemeinschaft zusammen steht quasi
auch als alle eine allianz des
internationalen rechts gegen diese
unrechtsstaaten aber wir müssen jetzt
endlich jetzt mit dieser dimension
umgehen auch umgehen lernen zum teil das
haben ja jetzt auch jüngste veränderung
in der deutschen politik gerade eine
ausrichtung in der sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik gezeigt wir sind
angekommen in der realität so wie putin
sie uns gerade auf den tisch legt hat
angekommen heißt dass die politik hat
sich auch zu wenig mit sicherheitsfragen
beschäftigt ja ich glaube das sieht man
jetzt überdeutlich
es hat ja auch vorlagen gegeben so kommt
es ja jetzt auch zu diesem 100
milliarden paket weil es im grunde um
vorarbeiten gegeben hat auch nach den
krisen der vergangenheit dass wir nicht
ordentlich ausgestattet sind zum
beispiel auch aus deutsche bundeswehr es
hat die anmahnung ja auch innerhalb der
nato gegeben mehrere präsidenten in aus
den usa haben das auch angemahnt dass
europa seinen teil auch zur
sicherheitslage zur verteidigung
beitragen soll
und wir waren zu spät wir waren in
vielen bereichen zu spät und das rächt
sich jetzt in einer situation wo jemand
eben nicht bereit ist sich an all das zu
halten was er auch selbst unterschrieben
hat in internationalen verträgen um ein
gemeinsames miteinander zu organisieren
auf der basis von regeln die alle
miteinander akzeptieren herr kiesewetter
oberst der bundeswehr sie waren lange
bei der bundeswehr das heißt sie kennen
die bundeswehr auch von innen aber sie
können natürlich auch die politische
bedeutung der vier sterne general ramms
hat gestern bei der ard gesagt dass man
immer zu wenig auf das militär gehört
hat ist das auch ihre erfahrung hat man
zu wenig als militär gehört wenn er
zumindest hat man seit 1990 die
bundeswehr systematisch abgebaut und sie
auch als steinbruch für finanzielle
zusagen und umschichtung innerhalb des
bundeshaushalts gesehen das war
tatsächlich bis 2014 bis zum erster
ukraine krieg der fall aber ist sie ist
eben nicht bestandteil unserer
sicherheitskultur gewesen die
sicherheitskultur deutschland zwar wir
sind von freunden und partnern umgeben
und können uns vorrangig und soziale
sicherheit oder wirtschaftliche
wettbewerbsfähigkeit kümmern aber die
dimensionen der äußeren oder inneren
sicherheit die wurde vernachlässigt und
in der bundeswehr hat man das massiv
gestört indem ihm die
einsatzbereitschaft zurückgefahren wurde
in dem der investitionsanteil also der
anteil der in ausrüstung und ausstattung
geht zurück gefahren wurde und dass wir
seit dem libyen-krieg 2011 die munitions
bestände der bundeswehr nicht mehr
aufgeführt haben allein das ist ein
defizit von über 20 milliarden euro wie
sehr hat man das denn in der bundeswehr
beklagt in der bundeswehr das immer
beklagt und auch angesprochen aber es
wurde politisch eben nicht umgesetzt und
es war seinerzeit eben kein thema und
wir hatten auch in der koalition
unterschiedliche vorstellungen darüber
wir konnten die trendwende einleiten
aber mit dem koalitionspartner weil es
eben nicht möglich dass zwei prozent
ziel umzusetzen so haben wir eben uns
auf anderthalb prozent geeinigt bis 2025
aber in der politik muss man kompromisse
suchen und leid tragen da war er eben
die bundeswehr jetzt sehen wir eine 180
grad wendung in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik aufgrund der
ereignisse 100 milliarden soll die
bundeswehr jetzt bekommen und damit soll
das zwei prozent ziel der nato auch
eingehalten werden sie sprachen es ja
eben schon an dass wir da längst nicht
waren die union unterstützt die vorhaben
der der ampel auch
müssen wir eingestehen dass das konzept
was bisher immer galt wandel durch
handel gescheitert ist also zunächst
einmal dass zwei prozent ziel wird nicht
mit den 100 milliarden eingehalten
sondern soll tatsächlich durch eine
erhöhung des bundeshaushalts in diesem
jahr noch um 18 milliarden eingehalten
werden die 100 milliarden kommen
obendrauf und da muss man sehr
sorgfältig schauen wie man das ändert
aber sie sprechen es an das narrativ
wandel durch handel hat nicht
funktioniert weil eben der diplomatische
teil zwar funktioniert hat aber nicht
der teil der härte also das war es
beispielsweise helmut schmidt und
genscher oder helmut kohl und genscher
ausgezeichnet hat das war die frage
verteidigungsbereitschaft und anstatt
entspannungs bemühungen und wir haben
halt nur auf entspannungs bemühungen
gesetzt und nicht mehr auf
verteidigungsbereitschaft das hat
russland gnadenlos ausgenutzt und auch
unsere bereitschaft alles zu tun dass
die ukraine keine perspektive in der
nato hat das hat deutschland mit
frankreich 2008 abgelehnt und 2014
abgelehnt das wurde von russland nicht
wertgeschätzt und am ende war das im
kreis sogar einen fehler am ende war es
ein fehler das heißt man hätte 2008
zustimmen sollen man hätte etwas anderes
bedenken soll 1994 war die ukraine die
drittstärkste nuklearmacht der welt und
sie haben nuclear abgerüstet alessandra
russland als rechtsnachfolger der
sowjetunion übergeben und 20 jahre
später aber das papier nichts mehr wert
auf dem stand das budapester memorandum
mit der folge dass wir heute weltweit
mit iran oder nordkorea deswegen nicht
mehr über nukleare abrüstung reden
können und entscheiden das eben auch
dass wir im nachhinein dem drängen der
amerikaner oder auch den nachrichten der
amerikanischen nachrichtendiensten
besser glauben hätten schenken sollen
mit blick auf eine stärkung der ukraine
aber jetzt müssen wir nach vorne schauen
rückblickend hilft uns nicht weiter frau
bär die ukraine wehrt sich gegen einen
unglaublich übermächtigen gegner wenn
man es sieht deutschland hat sich vor
dem kriegsausbruch während des
kriegsausbruchs lange hat lange gezögert
sanktionen durchzusetzen oder auch noch
zwei zu stoppen oder auch
waffenlieferungen
tatsächlich auf den weg zu bringen das
ist inzwischen der fall andere europäer
waren da viel schneller und auch
entschieden
würden sie sagen deutschland hat das vor
allen dingen gemacht weil es auch gefahr
lief sich zu isolieren innerhalb europas
dass sie die entscheidung dann so
getroffen haben ich glaube die strecke
waren ein bisschen länger wir haben ja
nun auch eine andere historie an dem
punkt ja ich hätte es mir auch schneller
gewünscht ich glaube man musste nicht
nur auf die amerikaner hören also ich
höre bei uns im europäischen parlament
insbesondere eben auch die kollegen aus
dem baltikum auch aus polen darüber also
entsprechend die grenzen auch haben da
war schon wesentlich früher eine ganz
andere einschätzung könne teilweise
jetzt auch eine andere einschätzung auch
der zustände in der russischen
bevölkerung
ich bin froh um das mal nach vorne
blicken zu sagen ich bin froh dass wir
jetzt diesen realismus haben ein klären
lassen und das jetzt auch wirklich
gute maßnahmen ergriffen werden manch
einer hätte auch vor vier wochen noch
nicht geglaubt dass eine ampel regierung
in der lage ist das zu tun das ist
natürlich auch eine ganze ampel
regierung darin wirklich nein ich glaube
wenn man auch gerade gestern abend zum
beispiel in die aussenministerin werbung
gehört hat dann merkt man eben dass
diese entschlossenheit auch da ist man
zu sehr sehr guter auftritt bei den
vereinten nationen das hat auch nochmal
vertrauen gestärkt dass wir
möglicherweise über diese etwas längere
strecke angekratzt hatten an diesem
punkt und das ist jetzt auch das
wichtige wir müssen in diesen sanktionen
zusammenstehen wir haben sicherlich noch
zu tun auch bei diesem paket noch
einzelne lücken zu schließen manches ist
auch nicht einfach wenn ich zum beispiel
an die ausweichmöglichkeiten in crypto
währungen oder anderes denke aber diese
entschlossen hat hat meines erachtens
putin auch überrascht das zusammenstehen
an diesem punkt und da sieht man eben
das doch schon auch aus vorangegangenen
krisen gelernt wurde dass wir
vorbereitungen getroffen haben wie wir
jetzt sogar hier sehr sehr schnell finde
ich auch sehr gut mit flüchten des htm
umsehen können das ist natürlich auch
etwas was auf der humanitären seite
extrem wählerisch muss trotzdem ja auch
dass wir jetzt die möglichkeit haben sie
jetzt erstmal reinzuholen dass wir eben
sofort auch leistungsbezug aus dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz ohne die
gesamten verfahren zu durchlaufen das
wir verteilen innerhalb europas das
wirklich zusammen dass sie sofort arbeit
möglichkeiten bekommen und die auch
aufnehmen können also alles das was wir
im vorangehenden zeiten ja bitter
gelernt haben oder dieser stelle ich
glaube das wird auch noch mal
stabilisierend wirken an den punkten
trotzdem wir müssen jetzt nach vorne
wir müssen schauen dass wir aus dieser
konflikt aus diesem krieg auch raus
sondern das heißt es muss jetzt erreicht
werden auch über strenge und
diplomatische ansätze endlich eine
waffenruhe herzustellen die humanitären
korridore auch möglichst stabil zu haben
um die menschen aus diesen situationen
erst einmal zu evakuieren aber dann auch
nach vorne zu schauen und genau das nach
vorne schauen das machen wir gleich nach
ich wollte gerne nochmal zumindest einen
kurzen blick nach nach hinten werfen hat
putin das zögern das anfängliche zögern
dann auch als schwäche interpretiert und
ihm deswegen auch in seinem aggressiven
handeln bestärken
ich glaube dass putin ohnehin eine nicht
allzu hohe meinung über die europäischen
mitgliedsstaaten und auch die
europäische union als solches hat er
sieht meines erachtens auf der anderen
seite nur die usa und wähnt sich einer
quasi unverbrüchlichen unterstützung
durch die chinesen so und dass das jetzt
in der art und weise doch schnell agiert
worden ist gemeinsam auch im
schulterschluss mit den werte partnern
ich glaube das hat die nachher dann doch
eher überrascht möglicherweise macht
auch das ihnen noch einmal aggressive
ich glaube es ohnehin immer weniger
einschätzbar außer quasi in seine weiter
eskalierenden wirkung aber sollte uns
das jetzt deswegen zurückschrecken
lassen ich glaube das ist ja genau das
was wir in den ganzen letzten zeiten
auch bei der krim annexion oder andere
falsch eingeschätzt haben nach dem motto
bis hierhin geht er und nicht weiter
mittlerweile wissen wir es
wahrscheinlich nicht zu stoppen außer
dass man wirklich jetzt hat man mit dem
spiel haben wir uns in putin auch
getäuscht ein stück weit hätte man das
vorher alles wissen können dass dieses
aggressive handeln was wir jetzt sehen
auch immer in seinem kopf war also das
umdenken fand glaube ich in teilen 2014
statt weil bei dem nato gipfel 2008 als
quasi der ukraine und georgien die
beitrittsperspektive so in ganz
niveaulose zukunft gestellt wurde haben
wir auch den cyber angriff russlands auf
island erlebt wir haben auch 2008 den
angriff auf georgen erlebt am
eröffnungstag der olympischen spiele
nimmt zur förderraten jahr erschossen
der oppositionsführer also es war schon
deutlich dass russland auch vor
politischen morden nicht zurückschreckt
zwischen 2000 und 2020 so putin übernahm
99 ab 2000 begannen politische morde
über 22 lee bekannt geworden sind
kulminiert in libyen janko mit polonium
also ein tatsächlicher nuklear anschlag
oder der tiergarten mord oder auch der
anschlag auf einer weile also das war
schon klar und wir haben hier immer sehr
verhalten mit ausweisung von zwei drei
primaten reagiert der hätten es wissen
müssen und es gab ja auch bei uns in der
fraktion große unterschiede 2014 nicht
alle waren damit einverstanden dass wir
eben nicht der ukraine weiterhelfen
sondern wir haben dann ja doch letztlich
auch überzeugt diesem diplomatischen
prozess dem minsker prozess um nochmal
die format zugestimmt aber spätestens
2016 hätten die alarmglocken läuten
müssen klingeln müssen weil 216 sich
russland aus dem münster prozess
zurückgezogen hat und zwei
separatistenführer an den tisch gesetzt
hat und da hat natürlich die ukraine
gesagt dann machen wir nicht mehr mit
und dann begann ja diese komische
aufsatz im letzten jahr sehr deutlich zu
sagen von putin im juni ukraine hat kein
existenzrecht im september wurden die
gasspeicher nicht mehr befüllt
weißrussland hat kein kein dünger mehr
geliefert ab oktober begannen die übung
und im januar wurden blutkonserven
ausgegeben an die truppen also das war
sehr geplant und orchestriert aber wir
haben es nicht so ernst genommen weil es
nicht glauben konnten das war nicht teil
unserer sicherheitsvorsorge aber wenn
sie das in dieser kette jetzt so
aufzeigen und wir vor allen dingen
dieses jahr 2014 15 16 noch mal zurück
gelegten das war genau die zeit als
deutschland dann die verträge für nord
stream zwei unterschrieben hat hätte man
da nicht viel früher schon anders
reagieren müssen und hat sich
deutschland dann nicht auch ein stück
weit isoliert es gab ja viele länder
dann sofort aufgeschrieben haben auch
innerhalb der eu auch frankreich mal
abgesehen von polen estland aber auch
schweden und anderen ländern also hier
sieht man tatsächlich auch den
unterschied in unserer in unserer
auffassung die sicherheitspolitiker
haben alle davon abgeraten ich zählte
dazu norbert röttgen wadephul hart aber
die wirtschaftspolitiker design er das
thema wandel durch und eben nicht die
sicherheitsprobleme und auch der
sicherheitspolitische berater im
kanzleramt hat seine sorgen geäußert
aber es haben sich die
wirtschaftspolitiker durchgesetzt und im
nachhinein muss man eben sagen wir
sicherheitspolitiker müssen
ganzheitlicher argumentieren müssen die
strategische kultur anmahnen und 2014
hat ja eine trendwende eingesetzt
zumindest bei der bundeswehr aber die
erschlaffte sofort wenn man das
kombiniert hat mit einer 41 stunden
woche und mit einer armee im einsatz ist
schwer und 1 41 stunden woche überall
durchzusetzen also wir sehen es war eher
so ein hin und her wie ebbe und flut und
heute sehen wir wir hätten etwas mehr
dämme bauen müssen aber war der fehler
nicht letztendlich auch dass man deutsch
entschieden hat ja also dass man die
jury europäischen kontext entschieden
wir uns wohl wissen dass sowohl energie
wir sehen uns ja jetzt selbst migration
natürlich geopolitisch auch eingesetzt
werden kann an dieser stelle also das
ist das wo ich glaube dass der
entscheidende fehler gemacht worden ist
ansonsten hätte man so ne sache nach als
musikalische kommission zu uns in den
bundestag europäische kommission und hat
sehr deutlich gemacht dass das ein
politisches ein geopolitisches projekt
ist und kein wirtschaftliches und es
wurde immer auch vom kanzleramt aber
eben auch vom koalitionspartner damit
auch von uns wir standen ja zusammen man
muss auch loyalität haben in der
koalition haben immer gesagt das ist ein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt und die
mahnenden stimmen insbesondere aus dem
auswärtigen ausschuss die wurden gehört
aber wir wurden eben nicht ernst
genommen es hilft aber im nachhinein
nicht deswegen sage ich wiederum lasst
uns nach vorne gucken und die fehler aus
den fehlern lernen aber nicht vermeiden
aber ich bin ganz bei ihnen frau bär wir
haben uns damit isoliert gegenüber den
baltischen staaten gegenüber der ukraine
gegenüber polen wir haben misstrauen
gesät und das war erst marco der das
ganze aufgebrochen hat indem er uns im
aachener vertrag quasi eine
beistandspflicht dabei
vertragsmäßig ausverhandelt hat und wir
dann erst das grüne licht von frankreich
bekommen haben für das projekt das war
18 oder 19
in deutschland hat auch das 2 prozent
ziel nicht eingehalten genau in dieser
zeit also hat sich auch dann stück wald
isoliert wurde immer wieder kritisiert
auch vor allen dingen von seiten der usa
trump ganz besonders aber auch beiden
hat das letztendliche war schon auch
obama schon genau
welche verantwortung trägt deutschland
jetzt bei der deutschen außenpolitik die
jetzt auch zu dem krieg führte wenn wir
das hören einerseits den ostring 2 und
das zwei prozent ziel nicht eingehalten
ist das eine verantwortung die
deutschland auch für diesen krieg trägt
das ist eine verantwortung für
deutschland eben auch schneller und
stärker jetzt umzusteuern weil natürlich
die augen der hauptstädte nicht nur aus
brüssel sondern auch aus den
hauptstädten der mitgliedstaaten in die
hauptstadt der größten volkswirtschaft
in der europäischen union geht und die
erwartung eben auch ist hier mit gewicht
einzubringen an dieser stelle deswegen
hausaufgaben zu machen die man die
kritik daran dass deutschland sich dann
auf 1,5 prozent geeinigt hat sie war ja
auch entsprechend wahrzunehmen ist
gerade auch von den freien demokraten
immer geäußert worden auch viel stärker
zu vernetzen den
verteidigungspolitischen aspekt eben mit
dem diplomatischen oder auch dem in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit weil auch
dort haben wir
strategisch quasi nicht alles das
rausgeholt was man hätte manche müssen
muss um in dem bereich ein sich
einzusetzen ja nein aber deswegen glaube
ich dass es jetzt wirklich eine neue
weichenstellung in die richtige richtung
ist die drei prozent für 3 d also eben
genau diese drei bereiche miteinander
vernetzt zum einsatz zu bringen dass wir
jetzt in der situation geraten nachdem
das endlich verankert ist dass wir jetzt
den verteidigungspolitischen aspekt so
viel stärker betonen müssen als wir in
dem konzert der 3 das gerne gehabt
hätten das ist ja traurig aber umso
wichtiger ist es dass jetzt dieser
kraftakt auch gelingt und deswegen finde
ich auch sehr verantwortungsvoll wenn
die cdu/csu wirklich dabei bleibt jetzt
auch bei der ermöglichung dieses
sondervermögens mit an einem strang zu
ziehen weil ja die augen der welt gehen
innerhalb von europa natürlich auch auf
die stärkste volkswirtschaft bislang ist
aber sag ich mal die führungsqualität
wirklich aus paris heraus und ich würde
mich freuen wenn wir da wirklich jetzt
stärker auch auf augenhöhe kommt so
heißt es den eigenen entschuldigung nur
zu unterstützen auch wenn die regierung
der eigene mehrheit hat aber ich möchte
das mit dem zwei prozent ziel noch mal
unterstreichen der ursprung des 2
prozent ziels ist deutschland die haben
nämlich wir haben in den 90er jahren den
ländern in mittel osteuropa gesagt wenn
ihr in die nato wollt dann müsst ihr
zwei prozent ihres bruttoinlandsprodukts
bringen wir hatten damals drei weil die
natürlich in den in der umschichtung aus
dem ehemaligen ostblock aus dem rat für
gegenseitige wirtschaftshilfe aus der
maroden industrie dann noch zwei prozent
zu erwirtschaften für verteidigung haben
wir ganz schön aufgelastet und umso
gravierender war ist sie haben es
angesprochen frau wäre das dann wir uns
dafür erst eingreifen wenn man sich die
deutsche außenpolitik nochmal anschaut
heißt es dass sie viel zu ökonomisch
ausgerichtet war und auch an sie noch
mal die frage inwiefern trägt
deutschland denn auch eine
mitverantwortung für diesen krieg wir
tragen dahingehend eine mitverantwortung
als wir zweimal die chance hatten die
ukraine enger an die nato und eu zu
binden gleichwohl müssen wir sagen dass
die ukraine größte schwierigkeiten hat
die europäischen ziele zu erreichen mit
blick auf korruptionsbekämpfung mit
klick auf gute steuersystem auch
bestimmte fragen der good governance
aber das ist doch kein grund die ukraine
hängen zu lassen hier hätten stärker
statt mit einer checkliste mentalität
stärker vor ort mit beratung da sein
müssen und werden viel stärker auf die
ganzen entschuldigung ich das so sage
timoschenkos und janukowitsch und
timoschenko schauen müssen was sie denn
mit dem beitritt hilfen machen wohin die
gelder fließen also das haushalts
controlling was früher im
europaparlament inge gräßle gemacht hat
dieses haushalts controlling das hat mit
blick auf die ukraine schon gefehlt und
wenn wir das mit begleitet hätten dann
wäre die ukraine deutlich eher beitritts
reif geworden und das haben wir schon
auch ein bisschen vernachlässigt
und ökonomisch meinte ich vor allen
dingen auch die energielieferung dass
sich deutschland auch letztendlich so
abhängig gemacht hat von russland und
zwar schröder und merkel haben das auch
den charme einen bereich wo wir beide
nicht regiert haben zwischen 98 und 25
auf der einen seite der ausstieg aus der
kernkraft bis 2020 der später revidiert
wurde um die erneuerbaren schneller zu
machen bis 35 und dann bei fukushima
wieder revidiert wurde aber parallel zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren wurde nord
stream 1 verhandelt 25 und dann ging der
bundeskanzler in der unter verkürzung um
ein jahr der legislaturperiode zwei
monate nach ende nach den
bundestagswahlen 25 in die dienste von
gazprom oder in russische dienste wie
wir heute wissen das ist schon sehr
bedenklich und es gehört auch zur
geschichte der bundesrepublik dazu dass
wir das mal aufarbeiten die es kommen
konnte dass wir neben den erneuerbaren
uns in so eine einzigartige in ganz
europa abhängigkeit von gas gegeben
haben in eine abhängigkeit von russland
das war glaube ich nicht nur
blauäugigkeit das war ein kalkül dass
ich jetzt bitter rächt ein kalkül würden
sie das auch so sehen ist deutschland
quasi adresse dort von putin und war das
ein großer fehler sich in eine solche
abhängigkeit zu beginn das war
sicherlich ein großer fehler sich in
solch einer abhängigkeit am zu begeben
weil wir sehen ja jetzt wie schwer es
uns fällt möglichst schnell möglichst
konsequent diese abhängigkeiten zu
reduzieren
das wird jetzt noch sehr viel mühe
kosten das sehen wir jetzt auch schon
sage ich mal in den lebenshaltungskosten
der bevölkerung aber es ist dringend
notwendig und deswegen gilt es jetzt
eben andere lieferanten andere
liefermöglichkeiten aufzutun es gilt
aber auch das undenkbare zu denken also
nochmal in der ganzen palette der
beschaffungsmöglichkeiten darüber
nachzudenken und das ist ja das woran
jetzt gearbeitet wird sowohl in den
mitgliedsstaaten auch hier in berlin als
auch auf der ebene der europäischen
union um wirklich da davon wegzukommen
tagtäglich noch milliarden zu überweisen
sie wohnt damit letztendlich die
kriegskasse bundeskasse erfüllen auch
wenn natürlich durch das sanktionsregime
insbesondere auch durch die sperrung der
zentralbank das geld jetzt nicht in
dermaßen einsetzbar ist wie das davor
der fall gewesen wäre aber das muss
jetzt passieren weil das zerreißt am
jahr regelrecht das ja muss man wenn man
sich die entwicklung anschaut nicht
zuletzt auch
sehen dass das sogar ein strategisches
ziel putin zwar durch stream 1 und 2 den
west und vor allem die eu auch zu
spalten und steckt es ist ihm zumindest
gelungen das in der wahrnehmung des
baltikums polens und auch der ukraine
deutschland hier ein sonderweg gegangen
ist und in der vergangenheit hat ja
polen unter dem deutsch sowie schon
sonderweg gelitten auch mit blick auf
rapallo und dann die frage des
deutsch-sowjetischen vertrages unter der
teilung polens das angriffs baltikums
und so weiter und so fort also da ist
schon ein grund auch historisch
begründetes grundmisstrauen da und hat
uns die historische sensibilität gefehlt
ich sage uns auch wenn das nicht unsere
regierung war weil das ja auch ganz
deutschland abfärbt und wir hätten mit
blick auf die erneuerbaren energien hier
deutlich mehr beschleunigen müssen da
schaue ich auch ganz eigene portal weil
wir natürlich was den leitungsausbau
angeht die frage der windkraft die
erdverkabelung viele mehr ein ziemlich
gelähmten prozess in deutschland haben
das muss ein ruck durchs land gehen und
wir müssen auch unsere bevölkerung sagen
dass das ganze einen preis hat wir
werden einige jahre den gürtel enger
schnallen müssen und ich erwarte schon
dass der bundeskanzler die
bundesregierung in dieser hinsicht auch
zeichen für eine eine ruckrede gibt hier
als union sind bereit das zu
unterstützen weil wir wollen dass unser
land weiterhin in der ersten liga spielt
historisch belegt war deutschland oder
hat deutschland ja immer so eine art
militärischer enthaltsamkeit geübt vor
allen dingen nach der einheit wollte man
auch nicht mit einer militärischen
stärke womöglich die anderen länder
verschrecken
die osteuropäischen staaten die
vertrauen deutschland und wollen auch
den schutz ist das richtig ja aber sie
wollen insbesondere auch den schutz der
nato deswegen ist dort natürlich sehr
begrüßen aufgenommen worden auch das
engagement der amerikaner der nato
überhaupt die truppenstärken dort auch
noch einmal auszubauen auch die manöver
um eben auch zu zeigen dass man dort
gewappnet ist und deswegen ist es auch
richtig dass wir jetzt eben auch noch
einmal
unterstützend an dieser stelle sind darf
gar kein zweifel sein dass jeder angriff
egal auf welches mitgliedsland und
gerade eben auch im baltikum dass das
eben die beistands klausel auch des
nato-vertrags entsprechend auslöst und
das ist eben auch etwas wo ich glaube
dass noch abschreckenden charakter auch
bei putin hat weil daran eben niemand
wirklich niemand einen zweifel lässt
aber das muss dann eben entsprechend
auch ausfinanziert und ausgestattet sein
diese historisch verankerte militärische
enthaltsamkeit und wenn ich es mal die
deutschland an den tag gelegt hat war
das nicht auch ein stück bequemlichkeit
sich vor verantwortung zu drücken na ja
wir sind ja seit 99 haben uns nicht mehr
vor verantwortung gedrückt sondern wenn
ich überlege erste golfkrieg 91 haben
wir sehr viel infomaterial und ich
glaube 12 milliarden d-mark damals für
den golfkrieg gegeben aber 99 im kosovo
krieg war die bundeswehr luftwaffe
erstmals beteiligt an einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung im
bosnien krieg waren wir beteiligt dann
haben wir ab dem elften september und
sehr stark in der nato über viele jahre
in afghanistan engagiert das kann man
sehr gemischt sehen aber es hat
natürlich sehr geprägt die
innenpolitische debatte und auch der
satz unsere sicherheit wird am
hindukusch geprägt wünschte ich mir ich
habe den satz noch nicht gehört dass
unsere sicherheit auch von der
sicherheit der ukraine abhängt also ich
denke hat schon ein umdenken
stattgefunden nur die bundeswehr war
dann total auf auslandseinsätze fixiert
die reserve wurde 2003 komplett abgebaut
wir haben keine heimatschutz strukturen
mehr und das rächt sich jetzt bitter
licht weil wir im rahmen der
katastrophenhilfe keine reserve
strukturen haben wir müssen uns jetzt
eine zivile reserve aufbauen und
überlegen wie wir die militärische
reserve aktivieren also da gibt es viel
nachholbedarf es geht ja bis hin zur
frage gesellschaftlicher pflichtdienst
oder wehrpflicht ich bin sehr sehr stark
für ein freiwilliges überzeugung unserer
bevölkerung haben eine menge zu tun das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz zum
beispiel katastrophen und
bevölkerungsschutz braucht auch muskeln
das könnte das technische hilfswerk sein
dass könnten blaulichtorganisationen
sein sie haben eine menge nachzuarbeiten
und damit sind die streitkräfte nur ein
teil der nationalen sicherheitsvorsorge
gerade was jetzt klimaschutz angeht
waldbrände was die ganze frage auch die
krisenvorsorge angeht wenn flüchtlinge
kommen ich glaube haben wir auch
gesellschaftlich nachzuarbeiten also ich
erinnere mich an viele debatten würden
jugendoffiziere überhaupt noch in
schulen gehen ist die beteiligung auf
öffentlichen veranstaltungen gewünscht
oder eher nicht gewünscht
also wenn man daneben bundeswehr und
auch ihren einsatz für die gesellschaft
auch gerade für den frieden auf der welt
wenn man den raus trinkt aus der schule
üblichen begegnen gerade aus den schulen
dann findet ist es natürlich auch
schwierig hier eine wertschätzung
auszudrücken dementsprechend eben auch
kompetente frauen und männer hyde zu
gewinnen für den dienst am auch den
dienst der zur not eben auch zum einsatz
mit der waffe sei es zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung sei in
internationalen einsätzen führt glauben
sie dass dieser krieg die
gesellschaftliche veränderung wird
schnell vorantreibt dass man da wieder
um denkt denn das war ja wie sie es
beschrieben haben es war ja auch nicht
gesagt da ist ich habe den eindruck ich
habe wir haben ja auch gesehen dass die
stimmung in der bevölkerung schon weiter
war als die umsetzung nachher eben
handeln von regierungen
nur müssen wir jetzt glaube ich auch die
emotionale ebene und auch die technisch
operative ebene zueinander bringen weil
viele dieser verfahren natürlich auch
hoch komplex sind und wir sie auch so
steuern müssen damit sie die richtigen
erreichen nämlich die oligarchischen
putin und die gesamten
rechtsverletzung an dieser stelle und
wir nicht nur uns letztendlich dabei ins
abseits stellen also deswegen ja ich
glaube bevölkerung ist hier auch schon
weiter wenn ich jetzt auf die weiteren
denkbaren sanktionen blicke nur wir
müssen es nachher natürlich im handeln
der institution ob nur auf der
europäischen ebene oder in den
mitgliedstaaten so aufsetzen das ist
auch in die richtige zielrichtung geht
nämlich putin da in seinem handeln jetzt
komplett zu isolieren die ukraine die
ukraine erwartet ja dass wir in dieser
lage noch weitere sofortmaßnahmen
treffen von seiten des westens auch dass
mehr militärisches gerät geliefert wird
da sind auch flugzeuge u-boote im
gespräch inwiefern bestätigen damit die
gefahr dass putin noch mehr gereizt wird
und eventuell das kriegsgebiet dann
nochmal daraus den putin ist ja nicht
gereizt sondern er macht das
absichtsvoll das ist ein langer plan der
krieg ist von lange vorbereitet das
rächt sich eben dass die frühzeitigen
warnungen
gehört wurden und die ukraine erst so
spät ausgestattet und unterstützt wird
jetzt hilft nur etwas was keine große
langwierige ausbildung hat also sprich
flugzeuge würden sich nur welche eignen
muster die auch in der ukraine geflogen
werden weil wir keine pilotenausbildung
leisten können und vor allen dingen
eines nicht machen können personal
dorthin schicken weil das einem
kriegseintritt gleichkäme entscheidend
ist dass wir das material senden und da
ist eine menge gemacht worden ich hoffe
nicht zu spät
es geht darum dass wir die existenz der
ukraine sichern die existenz eines
volkes das gerne der europäischen union
der nato der westlichen regelbasierten
ordnung angehören möchte steht auf dem
spiel und wir tragen die verantwortung
weil wir es diesem land sehr schwer
gemacht haben diese ordnung anzugehören
das land stand sich teilweise manchmal
auch selbst im weg aber es ja kein grund
jetzt diesem land anzubieten wie wir es
teilweise hören dass in der
exilregierung binden bilden sollen dass
sie neutral werden sollen dieses land
kämpft für uns um seine freiheit und
wenn die ukraine fällt dann fällt auch
moldawien dann gerät das baltikum unter
druck gut hin hört ja damit nicht auf
das hat er ja erklärt er der sehr klar
gesagt dass länder wie das baltikum die
mal der sowjetunion angehört haben kein
recht haben selbständig zu existieren
sie gehören nach russland und länder die
nach 97 der nato beigetreten sind haben
kein recht der nato angehören sein ziel
ist dass die amerikaner sich aus europa
zurückziehen alles formuliert und putin
hält sich anders das heißt wir
befürchten auch dass putin durchaus in
die baltischen staaten zum beispiel
einmarschiert wenn die ukraine fällt
wird er alles tun die europäische union
und die nato zu erpressen und das müssen
wir auch unsere bevölkerung sagen
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt stärke und
müssen sehr klar sagen dass wir auch
forderungen stellen abzug der
sowjetischen raketen aus kaliningrad
abzug der sowjetischen russischen
truppen aus transnistrien abzug der
russischen truppen aus dem besetzten
gebiet georgiens abzug der russischen
truppen dieser hilfe aus mali also es
gibt ja auch punkte von uns ich höre nur
zu wenig das dann auch von uns
forderungen gestellt werden und darauf
muss ja putin sich auch verhalten wir
hören immer nur seine forderungen wir
haben ganz klare forderungen und das
baltikum gehört zur nato zur
europäischen union und hat
uneingeschränkte souveränität vor der
inwiefern müssten diese forderungen
klarer ausgesprochen werden von seiten
zum beispiel der bundes regierung aber
auch von sollten brüssel
ich glaube dass das notwendig ist das
eine passagierin forderung ja vor allen
dingen muss man sich zurückziehen soll
auch so kleine und die kriegshandlungen
sofort stoppen sollen aber ja auch diese
forderung habe ich ja noch nicht sogar
in diesem unmittelbaren zusammenhang
aber ich bin da völlig bei ihnen klappt
wir brauchen auch den 360 grad blick wir
erleben gerade letztes wochenende dass
die der abschluss auch dass iran die
hits also das verhindern dass der iran
über atomwaffen
demnächst verfügt und die sind nah dran
dass das jetzt wieder verschoben wurde
weil russland plötzlich den konnex macht
zu dieser situation und ich glaube wir
müssen letztendlich
komplett über die erdkugel schauen an
dieser stelle um das auszutarieren
meines erachtens hat eine
schlüsselposition china bei genau dieser
schulterschluss zwischen russland und
china glaube ich putin noch in seiner
stärke wähnt wir haben einen
durchaus verhalten agierenden
chinesischen außenminister bei der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz gesehen
der schon auch auf die selbstbestimmung
der völker gebracht hat an dieser stelle
wem sie haben jetzt gesehen dass sie in
der un eben nicht mit den russen nicht
mit nordkorea und den schurkenstaaten
gestimmt haben sondern sich zumindest
enthalten haben aber das ist mir noch zu
wenig ich glaube wir müssen jetzt in der
internationalen staatengemeinschaft
china weit stärker auch in die pflicht
nehmen das was hier passiert kann auch
china nicht gefallen gerade auch vor dem
hintergrund der atomaren gefahren die
hier ausgelöst worden sind und
dementsprechend habe ich wirklich die
hoffnung dass wir durch das zeigen von
herta auf der einen seite aber auf der
anderen seite dann quasi auch von beiden
seiten einkesseln und isolieren putins
an dieser stelle agieren können muss man
den chinesen wahrscheinlich auch sagen
dass es ansonsten eben auch zu ihrem
schaden sein wird weil man dann
gegebenenfalls den blick weiten muss von
den abwehrmaßnahmen die wir momentan
vorne china hat vor allen dingen
wirtschaftliche interessen kiesewetter
aber natürlich auch durchaus
strategische interessen mit blick auf
taiwan wird hier ganz genau beobachten
was da jetzt gerade passiert
ich würde china sich da verhalten und
hier ist ja eine sehr interessanten
beobachterrolle sie sehen dass wir auf
die unterdrückungsmechanismen in
hongkong so gut wie gar nicht reagiert
haben dass die deutsche industrie ihren
fehler sicherlich auch dass die deutsche
industrie das thema der uiguren sehr
vorsichtig behandelt aufgrund möglicher
nachteile die sie erleiden können also
hier sehe ich schon auch die deutsche
wirtschaft in der pflicht und so politik
ist auch immer nur so stark wie die
wirtschaft bereit ist sanktionen
mitzutragen
aber ganz entscheidend wird sein wie
sich china verhält mit blick auf die
seitenstraße ukraine ist teil des
seitenstraßen projekts und wie sich
china in afrika verhält dort wird sich
glaube ich die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
europas entscheiden und dadurch dass die
ukraine ist getreide lieferant für
afrika in diesem jahr ausfällt werden
wir in afrika hungersnöte erleben in den
nächsten zwei drei jahren mit allen
möglichen folgen bis hin zur migration
und dann ist eben die frage schaffen wir
es als der freie westen dort zu helfen
oder tritt china als jemand auf der das
vorausgesehen hat denn der
schulterschluss zwischen putin und die
camping während der olympischen spiele
war doch sehr eindeutig dass quasi der
chinesische staatspräsident das vorgehen
putins sanktioniert hat halt klar war
der chinesische außenminister da etwas
zurückhaltend aber im grunde genommen
haben sie das gesamte vorhaben der der
russlands in der ukraine so weit es ging
mitgetragen weil sie natürlich nutzen
dieser sind der westen nutzt sich ab hat
große schwierigkeiten im
wirtschaftlichen nachteile in kauf und
china kann daraus dann neue stärke
gewinnen das müssen wir sehr genau
beobachten ich sehe das sehr kritisch
wenn wir noch mal den blick zurück auf
die ukraine richten wie die ukraine hat
direkt zu beginn der kriegshandlungen
auch die aufnahme in die eu beantragt
da gab es sehr emotionale debatten auch
schon im eu parlament dazu mit einer
botschaft von präsident selensky
wie soll denn eine schnelle aufnahme
überhaupt in eu
stattfinden können denn wir wissen wir
dass beitrittsverhandlungen und sich
unendlich in die länge ziehen können es
gab aber erst mal auch ein sehr
deutliches signal des europäischen
parlaments jetzt möglichst schnell
diesen kandidatenstatus auch zu gewähren
und ich glaube es geht nicht anders als
das was wir schon angesprochen haben
dass man weit stärker noch begleitend
unterwegs ist als quasi buchhalterisch
natürlich müssen kriterien eingehalten
werden wir haben die kopenhagener
kriterien damit eben diese gemeinschaft
mache auch zueinander passt weil nach
alle mitglieder ich sage einmal etwas
überspitzt des selben clubs daher auch
die selben regeln einhalten und bei sich
auch umsetzen müssen da sind noch wege
zu gehen bei korruption bei governance
und anderen aber ich halte es für immens
wichtig dass dieses politische signal
kommt jetzt diesen kandidatenstatus wo
ja auch schon häufig lange lange zeit
vergeht bis in diesen diskussionen da
mal den knopf darauf gemacht wird den
jetzt eben zu zeigen gerade wenn wir
alle miteinander
unterschreiben dass die ukraine jetzt ja
heldenhaft in dieser auseinandersetzung
geben die freie welt verteidigt das sind
unsere werte die wir teilen und dann
muss entsprechend natürlich da auch eine
schnelle antwort dafür braucht 27 länder
die dazu stimmen wir geschlossen ist der
eu denn und der stelle ich glaube die
können die geschlossenheit können wir an
dieser stelle auf der seite der
mitgliedstaaten noch erhöhen die direkt
gewählten volksvertretungen
volksvertreter haben das schon
vorgemacht also da ist man schon einen
schritt weiter kann man denn ein
aufnahmeverfahren kiesewetter so
beschleunigen dass es tatsächlich die
ukraine stabilisieren könnte der gehören
immer zwei dazu und wir müssen aufpassen
dass wir jetzt nicht einen sonderstatus
für die ukraine entwickeln warum weil
wir auch auf dem balkan eine reihe von
staaten haben die gerne eu mitglied
werden wollen und es mittelfristig
unbedingt auch werden müssen weil sie
sonst dauerhaft nicht arbeitsfähig sind
ich denke hier beispielsweise an
albanien und kosovo ich denke an bosnien
mazedonien montenegro das sind alles
länder die sehr spielball geworden sind
von st die arabien der türkei auch von
russland russland aber auch von
organisierter kriminalität und ich
glaube dass wir hier einen neuen ansatz
brauchen vielleicht einen
zwischenschritt hin zu einem art
drittstaaten abkommen was man jetzt mit
england verhandelt vielleicht muss man
das beschleunigt machen für die ukraine
in bestimmten fragen wo man es vorzieht
und dann darüber einen einen schnelleren
beitritt ermöglicht aber wir dürfen
keine illusionen uns hingeben das wird
mehrere jahre dauern und vielleicht kann
man diesen zwischen status schon in
diesem oder im nächsten jahr bekommt das
ist unverrückbar ist also es muss nach
außen ein zeichen kommen es sind noch
wenige jahre dann seid ihr vollmitglied
aber dazwischen habt ihr einen
besonderen status
inwiefern wirkt das denn auf putin das
glauben sie das denn heißen kalten krieg
noch einmal anheizen eine aufnahme der
ukraine in die eu nein ich glaube ist
unterstreicht vor allem die
entschlossenheit sich dem entgegen zu
setzen auch
geschlossen sich in dem entgegenzusetzen
etwas was er ja schon finnland schweden
gesehen hat die bedrohung auch mit blick
auf die nato an der er dazu geführt dass
in diesen ländern noch ein stärkerer
schulterschluss auch mit der nato ist
sie haben jetzt die möglichkeit auch
teilzunehmen an den entsprechenden
beratung regelmäßig eingeladen zu sein
also meines erachtens ging der schuss
für putin nach hinten los und
dementsprechend halte ich es für ein
wichtiges signal da jetzt auch nicht zu
weichen weil eben jeden meter den man
ihn in der vergangenheit gegeben hat hat
man gesehen der wirt eingenommen und
anschließend werden die forderung weiter
draufgesattelt
wenn wir uns jetzt die eu ein stückweit
angucken dann wird dieser krieg wenn man
auch nur ein stück weit etwas positives
daraus ziehen kann zumindest
integrierend was die eu angeht
wenn man sich vor allen dingen auch die
haltung zur flüchtlingsfrage von 2015
noch einmal vergegenwärtigt haben wir
jetzt eine ganz andere situation gerade
polen macht schlagzeilen mit einer
unglaublichen hilfsbereitschaft die sie
an den tag legen ein putin damit die eu
auch wirklich ein stück weit ich glaube
mehr als er geglaubt hat aber geradezu
polen die haben ja schon 2014 15 sehr
viel getan indem sie über eine million
ukraine aufgenommen haben und sich
deshalb halt damals auch dem aufnahme
mechanismus für menschen aus afghanistan
oder syrien oder irak verschlossen haben
es ei nicht und es eigentlich auch in
eine andere richtung schweden und
finnland sehr stark überlegen ob sie
nicht nato mitglied werden wollen aber
in jedem fall diese europäische
solidarität die schnelligkeit in den
sanktionen ich wünsche mir jetzt noch
dass es uns gelingt uns von russischem
öl und gas rasch unabhängig zu machen
für ein halbes jahr können wir uns das
leisten
danach sieht man sicherlich weiter aber
wir können es uns nicht leisten dass die
europäische union jeden monat etwa 600
mio eur an energie lieferungen bezahlt
und wir können uns auch nicht leisten
dass die usa bisher jedes jahr etwa 30
milliarden us dollar gezahlt haben an
russland für öllieferungen also da
müssen wir uns schon transatlantisch
stärker abstimmen aber ich glaube es hat
uns auch transatlantisch geeint also
nicht nur innerhalb der eu oder der
europäischen nato staaten sondern auch
transatlantischen das ist ein ganz
wichtiges signal finde ich auch an die
us-regierung und auch an beiden dass wir
daran interessiert sind weiterhin an
einem amerika das an europa ein starkes
interesse hat wenn wir ihm den rücken
freihalten also dass wir auch ein
zeichen setzen wir unterstützen eine
politik wie sie beiden macht damit wir
kramp verhindern dass wir also auch eine
meiner beiden geführten regierung den
rücken stärken um eine rückkehr von
trend zu erschweren denn da wird es für
europa schwer glaube ich
und die einigkeit europas oder der eu
können gerade an der flüchtlingsfrage
auch wieder ein stück weit vielleicht
sogar wieder brechen 1,5 millionen
flüchtlinge zur zeit schon unterwegs
werden wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel
mehr kann die eu das schaffen wie geht
man doch so samt jetzt besser
vorbereitet wir haben ja schon gemeinsam
agiert als wir gesehen haben wie von
belarus aus flüchtlinge im grunde also
politische waffe eingesetzt worden sind
wir haben uns vorbereitet und gehe jetzt
am freitag durch den innenministerrat
eben auch dieses temporäre flüchtlings
direktive in kraft gesetzt was eine
gemeinsame bearbeitung aller maßnahmen
auch entsprechend umsetzt und wir sehen
es ja jetzt auch wie zusammen gearbeitet
wird wie menschen aufgenommen werden wie
wir logistisch unterstützen und
entsprechend den menschen hier auch
aufnahme bereit stellen ich finde
allerdings auch bemerkenswert wie viel
hilfsbereitschaft wieviel
aufnahmebereitschaft wir in den
gesellschaften haben es kommen ja ganz
ganz viele daneben auch privat unter sei
es im verwandtschaft bereich aber eben
auch ein ganz normaler bevölkerung ich
glaube das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges
signal auch das eben auch diese
durchhaltekraft das sind ja meistens
dann getrennte familien die männer
bleiben in der ukraine um eben auch
weiter gegen die aggressoren zu kämpfen
und die frauen kinder alte menschen sind
dann hier ich glaube das macht auch noch
mal eine effekt aus in diesen
gesellschaften wie herzlich hier die
aufnahme ist und dass man wirklich sehr
unbürokratisch diesmal vor geht eben
nicht mit dem bleistift dasteht sondern
eben mit einem warmen herzen im angebot
großbritannien nicht ganz so aber die
kommen wir vielleicht auch noch dazu
herr kiesewetter zum ende der sendung
die frage haben sie die hoffnung dass
uns bilder wie wir sie aus grosny oder
aleppo kennen was die ukraine angeht
erspart bleiben und haben sie ideen wie
eine kompromisslinie eventuell eine
waffenruhe aussehen könnte
ich befürchte dass wir noch schlimmere
bilder sehen werden und ich befürchte
auch dass alle bemühungen für
vermittlung erst dann erfolg haben wenn
putin ausweglos dasteht deshalb sollten
wir alles tun dass wir akzeptieren dass
die ukraine einen freiheitskampf hat
dass wir sie nicht aufgeben sondern dass
wir sie ermuntern denn russland kommt
weitaus schwieriger voran als gedacht
wir sollten aber auch sehr klar sagen
dass die humanitären korridore nicht
nach russland führen dürfen und auch gar
nicht über vermintes gebiet da sollten
200.000 menschen aus mario pohl
evakuiert werden und dann hat das
internationale rote kreuz festgestellt
dass die rege vermied sind und 300
menschen kamen durch aus dieser zynismus
den müssen wir international sehr klar
ansprechen und damit uns diese bilder
erspart bleiben erwarte ich auch eine
aufwertung des internationalen roten
kreuzes und wir müssen uns gedanken
machen wie wir die vereinten nationen
wieder glaubwürdig und handlungsfähig
machen denn sie sind durch russland
gelähmt wir brauchen da eine reform aber
kurzfristig glaube ich ist ist die
lösung im humanitären korridor in
humanitären waffenstillstände zur
unterstützung aber weder wird die
ukraine ihren freiheitskampf aufgeben
noch wird putin von seinem ziel ablass
und das ziel muss sein dass putin in
russland keine zukunft hat für ihn gibt
es keinen gesichtswahrenden ausweg außer
den rücktritt wenn wir das noch mal
aufnehmen mit putin können sie sich
vorstellen dass putin jemals wieder
falls dieser krieg irgendwann beendet
sein sollte mitglied der internationalen
gemeinschaft sein kann nein ich glaube
das ist nicht möglich und das macht
sicherlich auch ein teil jetzt dieses
verzweiflung aus da regieren zu müssen
gerade auch vor dem innenpolitischen
hintergrund
ich glaube es ist von draußen momentan
ganz ganz schwer einschätzbar wie sich
die mehrheiten auch innerhalb der
gesellschaft verteilen weil das ein
großer unterschied macht ob jungen und
in städten oder älter und auf dem land
aber wir müssen meines erachtens schauen
dass wir eben auch gerade die
zivilgesellschaft in russland stärken
dass wir mit informationsangeboten
reingehen gegen diese ja zensur und des
informationskampagnen weil das was mit
leuten macht wenn sie tagtäglich
eigentlich nur hören ja wir gehen da zur
befreiung wie entnazifizierung ich meine
von einem jüdisch stämmigen präsidentin
das ist schon obskur was man da erlebt
beim menschen glauben dass und das wird
ein ganz ganz wichtiger anhaltspunkt
sein und deswegen finde ich es auch gut
dass die internationale
staatengemeinschaft ja nicht nur in der
un auch mit den instrumenten die wir zum
beispiel über den international criminal
corden haben und anderes als erste mal
diese maßnahmen ergreift jetzt schon
frühzeitig in ermittlungen zu gehen weil
das sind akte gegen die menschlichkeit
die da passieren dass ihm
kriegsverbrechen und genauso muss man es
auch bezeichnet vielen dank für diese
angeregte diskussion hier am tisch und
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen sehr herzlich
für das zuschauen über alle laufenden
entwicklungen hexe phoenix natürlich auf
dem laufenden im linearen und auch im
netz und warum 22.15 zensierte
phoenix-runde ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen guten abend basel
[Musik]